when you're on stage at the [ __ ] medal
battle every band has to rock the house
and Israeli outfit walkways spent months
rehearsing for their big moment
I think it's like the the craziest show
ever that we've had right the crowd was
crazy we didn't have such a big crowd
ever amazing amazing I would love to go
up one more time right now walkways
started out in 2006 under a different
moniker and eventually released their
debut album seven years later safe and
sound but these aren't your average
meadow heads actually super nerds
everybody here is a is an earth we
actually read books and watch science
films and we we just happen to play
metal back in Tel Aviv the five buddies
are very much local heroes
the Israeli Medal scene is a small but
vibrant one comprising around a hundred
bands and a few thousand committed fans
lots of good talent lot tons of great
bands even we had to compete with many
of our friends bands that we really
appreciate to get here in may 2015 they
won the Israeli playoff for the meadow
battle and in July they set out for
Germany as the metal world descended on
lowly [ __ ] mud is an integral part of
any self-respecting festival and
walkways know how to get into the spirit
of things but their primary focus is
always on their performance we used to
the stage we live on stage we love the
stage but we planned this metal bottle
who planned it for a three month we
practice practice for that so it's a lot
of energy that comes right to this
moment
the 2015 battle pitted 28 bands against
each other each allotted just 20 minutes
to while the audience and jury
and the second place went two ways from
Israel awesome shock than awesome feel
incredible way over and beyond our
expectations I think hopefully that
fantastic showing will bring their dream
of tour in Europe a big step closer